what are people telling you as far as
the walkification of the military is
that real i mean have are they changing
yeah i mean we we've i've talked about
this over the years it seems from a lot
of my friends um not every unit but
there are specific units and the
cultures that have been changing because
when you have
a lot more progressive leadership that
comes into the white house and and other
portions of
the country
their influence over generals and
admirals and and name the brass that top
down right top down comes from culture
and
yeah i i don't know this whole like
mandatory vaccination thing in the
military i mean it seems as we're just
trying to create a weak force which is
like the opposite of being a war fighter
like it's okay to have tattoos and
you're going out on target with your
friends to
kill or capture high-value targets like
that's a real job and it's you need
people that signed up for that i'm
trying to be very uh
casual with my statements there but
the whole purpose of being in the
military is is to fight wars and win
them